I apologize
I'm about to step onto brand new land
and literally yes it is a little bit
under water right now because well that
river there is in flood but 50 years ago
this would have been open water and I
would have been jumping off this boat up
to my neck and yes I was extremely
nervous about that jump but yeah this is
the wax lake Delta 50 years ago no trees
no plants nowhere to put your feet I
would have been swimming on a coastline
that's famous not for building up but
for eroding and to explain why we have
to go just a little bit inland the
Mississippi River is so murky and brown
because it's filled with silt and
sediment throughout history roughly
every thousand years or so deposits of
that segment build-up nothing but the
river basically blocks itself and then
takes a different tune Steven Ruby ocean
at least until self built up on a new
route and again that massive and
relatively sudden change is called an
avulsion and avulsions were fine until
modern times when the industry that you
can hear and the livelihoods of untold
numbers of people rely on the river
being exactly where it is but in the
past every time the humans have tried to
fix the rivers around here
there have been unintended consequences
we built levees like this wanted to take
towns like Baton Rouge here but they
make the river flow faster and higher
because all the water
into one channel and because they
restrict water flood they move the
flooding
upstream which means the next
neighborhood over has to build there may
be higher to deal with it there are
regulations to prevent levee Wars when
communities have to keep building their
levees higher because their neighbors
are doing the same those regulations and
downstream levees mean that instead of a
wider river during floods you get a
faster River eroding away those Sylvan
sediment deposits literally washing away
the land that he once created and now
the river doesn't flood as much so the
ground next to it dries out in seconds
and sinks Louisiana's coast line is
disappearing in 2011 government
cartographers retired 35 placements
taking them off the maps because those
islands and bays just don't exist
anymore they're just open water but
there is one place on the coastline
couple of hours south of Baton Rouge
where land is appearing again and that
is also an unintended consequence which
brings us back to where I was standing
at the Wyss like the wax-like
outlet is a channel off the Atchafalaya
River the Atchafalaya River is a channel
off the Mississippi so a channel off the
channel off the Mississippi River excuse
me I heard a little thunder okay no
let's get out of here
okay
no wax-like outlet was built in the
early 1940s and it was designed to pull
water off the Atchafalaya River and
reduce flood stress on Morgan City one
of the unintended consequences was the
development of a delta at the mouth of
the wax-like outlet and so the wax lake
outlet and the Atchafalaya River carries
a lot of sediment and then when it gets
to the coast the river flow slows down
and all of the the sediment in the river
settles out we're talking tens of
millions of metric tons of sediment
every year this is solid enough land
that you can walk on it and you can
stand on it Louisiana has lost nearly
2,000 square miles worth of land over
the last century and there's a large
effort to rebuild the coast a big part
of that effort is to try to partially
divert the flow of the Mississippi River
to create new Delta's that are like the
wax-like Delta and so people like myself
want to study the wax-like Delta so we
understand how Delta's build so we can
better design coastal restoration
projects it's important to restore the
coves one to push back the sea to
enhance flood protection in Louisiana
and it's also a place where you could
potentially bury carbon you know we have
too much co2 in the atmosphere and
highly productive Delta's like the wax
lake may be one of those places where we
can do that I often feel like the
numerical models that we have to
understand the coasts are pretty darn
good the much more difficult thing to
model is to understand people and how
people are gonna behave with this change
in Coast and I feel like that we barely
even know the equations we don't
necessarily know even what the rules are
to govern how do people deal with a
stressful changing environment so yes
it's still wet underfoot here right now
because this whole area is still in
flood but that just means there's more
mud more sediment being deposited this
land is gonna be a couple of centimeters
higher and this coastline is gonna be
just a little bit safer I've sunk about
an inch into the mud and it's going my
shoes it's it's in my shoes right I
should tell me on the sandals
ah all right